Nó giấu thế giới tông hoàn trông phía đồ tòn khi xung đồ Mỹ, Isran và Irran Liao Thang, làm giản đoạn vấn tải năng lượng qua xung đông.
Giờ Grand có lúc bỏ linh 8,5 phẩy bà mình bẩy đồ lắm ý một thông, mất cạo nhất trong nhiều tháng trước khi đều trình trong khi giấu về két tế ý cũng tăng hơn, sau đến bẩy tình trăm.
Một số tổ chức dự bảo Grand có thể giá đồng từ tắm mới đến chiếm mới đồ lắm ý một thông trong anh hạn như càng thẳng kéo dài.
Trong tâm lông ai ở biển thông út, nơi trụ chuyển khoảng 20% lượng dầu và khi tự nhiên hỏi lòng, lượng, anh ở gờ, bọn gồm, hàng chăm tầu trở dầu và khi tự nhiên hỏi lòng đã phải tháng nèo, hai bên tự nhiên này, gió giấu gió ăn ninh và bảo hiểm tân cao, inét bà tầu trở dầu bị chúng tên lượng, một tuyền biệt thình mạm.
Trong khi tí trường theo dõi sát người cơ ngãi của mỗi cơ mỗi lâm đến 2 mi trở thù một ngày.
Trời trời xuất thổ dầu mỏ lượng như thế giới, ông phải cộng thông báo tăng sản lượng thêm 2 trong lệ sống như thù một ngày từ tháng thứ.
Sông dưới phần tích trở dăng, mất tăng này mạng tính biểu tượng và khó bù đất, nếu giản đoạn kéo dài.
Đến đặc năng lượng kéo theo lãng sống nế dù gió trên tí trường về chính, trường khoảng trù án, trù án và hợp đồng tương lai Mỹ đồng là dạm.
Già vang thế giới tăng một phản nọc tình trọng lên 5 mi in ba trong nằm đồng lâm i một ảo s, lợi sốt trạc khi ông nghĩ xuống mất thấp nhất trong ba tháng.
Đồng đồng là Mỹ vào khoảng trù ý xí mạc lên trong khi ơ uống và cá đồng tiền nhẹ cảm với tăng trường như là CEO.
Tại Mỹ, già sạm bà lệ đủ sự báo vừa 8 đồng là Mỹ một gà lông lên đầu tiên trong hơn ba tháng.
Dưới phần tích cách báo nếu xung đột kéo dài, án lượng lãng phát toàn cầu có thể giả tăng vô cá lước những cầu lớn vài trình đến biệt sạm giữ trước quà cắt giảm như cầu.